[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم عطلان يتسبب في تاجيل
والغاء الاف الرحلات في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خلل في حواسيب النظام الفيدرالي
للاشعارات الجويه يؤثر على حركه المطارات
الامريكيه والدوليه المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض تقول انه لا يوجد دليل على وقوعه
هجوم الكتروني في هذه المرحله واداره
الطيران تعلن ان جميع الطائرات اصبحت امنه
للهبوط والاقلاع
على وقع انباء المتباربه بشان السيطره على
مدينه فوليدار الاوكرانيه النيتو يؤكد
الحاجه لزياده مستوى الدعم العسكري في حين
تبدي موسكو استعدادا لحل الازمه بالتفاوض
وتتهم الغربه واوكرانيا بعدم السماح
باجرائها في انقر لقاء روسي لابحث قضايا
انسانيه عالقه من بينها ملف الاسره
الجنيه المصري يواصل الهبوط اذا سجل ادنى
مستوى له على الاطلاق امام الدولار حيث
تجاوز سعر صرف الدولار حاجز 30 جنيها وذلك
بعد تعرض العمله المصريه لضغوط بسبب رفع
البنك المركزي لاسعار الفائده وطرح اكبر
مصرفين في البلاد شهادات ادخار بمعدلات
فائده قياسيه
الى وثائقي كشفها تحقيق ما خفي اعظم
المحكمه العليا النمساويه تصدر قرارا يقضي
باغلاق ملف الاتهام بالارهاب ضد
البروفيسور فريد حافظ من اصول المصريه
الذي وجهت له التهم خلال حمله شهيره
شهدتها البلاد عام 2020
الى اللقاء